Hey, this is really crazy video that people
are up in arms about because it is just so
whacked out.
This is video from July 30 first.
So the video is a month old, little over,
just over a month old, but it's somehow flew
under the radar until yesterday.
Donald Trump did a roundtable on July 30,
first with the National Association of Police
Organizations leadership as a protest of is
as a sort of counterprogramming when protests
of police brutality were raging in the United
States at the time.
And very similarly to Trump's recent statements
about what happened in Kenosha, about what's
going on in Portland.
Trump at this event generalized that the protesters
are the violent anarchists and they are determined
to assault police officers.
Police officers are in danger.
Police officers are the victims, despite,
of course, being the ones who hold the power
in the power dynamic that exists with law
enforcement.
And Trump went off on a tangent about protesters
throwing things frozen bottles of water, bricks,
whatever.
And then Trump went into a one minute long,
bizarre attack on cans of soup and bags of
soup.
What the hell is a bag of soup?
The video somehow slipped under the radar
back on July 30 first.
It is something else.
Take a look at this.
It's water.
And then they have cans of soup, soup and
they throw the cans.
So that's better than a brick because you
can't throw a brick.
Too heavy.
But a can of soup.
You can really put some power into that, right?
And then when they get caught, they say, oh,
this is soup for my family.
They're so innocent.
This is soup for my family.
It's incredible.
And you have people coming over with bags
of soup, big bags of soup, and they lay it
on the ground and the anarchists take it and
they start throwing it at our cops and our
police.
And it it hits you.
That's worse than a brick because it's got
force.
It's the perfect size.
It's like made perfect.
And when they get caught, they say, no, this
is just soup for my family.
And then the media says, this is just soup.
These people are very, very innocent.
They're innocent people.
These are just protesters.
Is that wonderful to allow protesting now?
And by the way, the media knows it better
than we do.
They know what's going on.
I don't know what's wrong with them.
They're doing our country.
So the extra component of bags of soup is
just extra funny.
It reminds me of when Trump.
In one of those montages for the RNC interviewed
workers who had recovered from covered.
And one worker said, I'm a custodian at the
post office.
And Trump said, oh, what?
What do you do?
And it was just one of these moments where
Trump is just so out of touch, where he doesn't
understand what a custodian does.
You know, most people who grew up in normal
childhoods know what a custodian does.
That does or, you know, did, particularly
if if you're proficient in English.
And this is a similar moment where Trump throws
in bags of soup.
Now, I have seen pouches, Manish Shavitz,
you can get a sort of pouch of the dry ingredients,
which then you mix with water.
But I don't know that Trump is talking about
those Manish Evatt's pouches when he talks
about bags of soup.
But listen, I guess we have to take seriously
the weaponization of soup.
I've always actually been a little suspicious
of so-called alphabet soup.
That sounds weird to me.
I don't know that that that seems a little
bit dangerous to me.
Of course, you can only bag certain soups
like a bisque probably does not lend itself
to being bagged.
But I've got a bag of chowder before.
Both Manhattan and New England style clam
chowder really, really work well in a bag.
This actually really is the exact type of
trump.
Going somewhere in his mind where we can't
tell whether it's a joke or something is wrong
with him.
And of course, Trump has no sense of humor.
So we very quickly end up at like.
Something seems to be very, very wrong with
this guy.
It's a delusional rant about weaponized soup.
And then, by the way, worse than bricks like
on the facts.
I don't think that Trump is actually correct.
And if you step back for just a moment.
If this was your relative.
Wouldn't you immediately say they need a full
neuro psych eval?
Like when we interviewed Dr. Bandy Lee, I
guess it was three weeks ago now, two, three
weeks ago, and she said, you know, the symptoms
are there to warrant a neuro psych eval doesn't
mean you're diagnosing anything, but there's
enough going on where you would want that.
Does this qualify?
Because this seems very, very strange and
it would be weird if it was anybody in your
family.
It happens to be the president of the United
States.
And as usual, it's like, yeah, people wrote
to me about how funny this is.
It is funny.
It's funny in a superficial way.
But once we're the laughing stock of the world
and we're the pity of the world, it's not
really all so funny anymore.
And it actually hasn't been funny for a long
time.
Will we ever know the full truth of what is
behind rants like these?
Does anybody after the fact say, hey, Mr.
President, you know, sir, as he likes to say,
the material about weaponized bags of soup
that was not so good.
That doesn't really resonate with with people.
My belief at this point, given what we know
about Trump's personality, is that the people
around him aren't willing to go up to him
and say that we know that anybody who's willing
to say to Trump what you're saying doesn't
make any sense.
They don't last very long.
And we've seen more than 500 people move on
from this administration over the last four
years.
I just don't think it's welcome at all.